good evening everyone please be seated
good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press in
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council the usual housekeeping
announcements far evacuation procedure
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs either
through the security doors to my right
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in holy square on the green
officers will assist you and revise when
it seemed safe to return to the chamber
webcasting a proceedings the Proceedings
of the meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the Internet
filming of a meeting I would advise that
a filming takes place anyone in
attendance in the public areas may have
their image captured I urge anyone
filming proceedings to avoid filming
members of the public particularly if
there are children present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
this evening I've got one two people is
there three yes three any member of the
public who objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to leave the meeting any
filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion
Crescent public from the meeting finally
the restriction on the use of mobile
phones with everyone present please
ensure their mobile phones are turned to
silent and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber while
this meeting is in progress thank you
very much indeed members right moving
straight on to agenda item 1 apologies
for absence apologies have been received
from councilors Paul Moore and
got are there any other apologies for
absence this evening
councillor Piper Thank You chairman
councilor Braidwood
is around holiday councillor bravely any
other apologies councillor David Hart
mr. chef are there any others I don't
see any others thank you very much
moving on to agenda item 2 minutes of
the previous meeting held on the 5th of
September 2019 I move that the minutes
of the meeting of the council held on
5th of September 2019 be approved and
signed as a correct record with the vice
chairman please second second did mr.
chairman do members agree thank you very
much
Genda item 3 announcements it is with
regret that I have to announce that
former councillor Denis Payne has
recently passed away and mr. Payne was a
Conservative councillor from 1979
through to 1995 and 2003 to 2007 it is
also with regret that I have to announce
that former councillor Jon Fullerton has
also recently passed away mr. Fullerton
was a Conservative councillor from 1999
through 2007 I'm sure that counts will
join me in expressing sympathy to both
mr. Payne and mr. Fullerton's families
good all members please stand for a
minute's silence as a mark of respect
thank you very much members
does any member wish to say a few words
to both these men Thank You chancellor
Tomlinson no my yes I have
Thank You chairman looking around the
chamber and the public gallery I'm not
sure whether many people here would
remember councillor pain or Dennis as we
got to know him way back in the eighties
with my involvement in the town yes I
got to know him he became mayor of the
town on two occasions and was honored to
be a Burgess that the Margate charged
trustees granted him he had quite a
career not just on this council but also
during the World War two he always told
us how he helped Winston Churchill on
the d-day landings which sometimes we
had a little bit of a smile back for
those who knew him he was a lovely man
he was taken ill in middle of the summer
I heard about it and councillor Taylor
here who lived opposite him in Margate I
know the family would say thank you Gary
because Gary was quite near and kept an
eye he was taken to hospital I visited
him on a couple of occasions very sad to
see he sadly passed away you know
playing August and he was buried last
week which we attended a lovely man he
will be missed
Thank You chairman thank you very much
indeed councillor Tomlinson councillor
Saunders have you a few words Thank You
chairman yes I'd like to speak with
regards to John Boyd or Fullerton unlike
councillor Bay furred and councillor
Savage who knew John in the council I
knew John outside the council for the
various groups that both counsel made
Saunders and I were actively associated
as has already been said John was an
elected councillor during the late 1990s
and into the new millennium
both locally
at County Council level and he served
for 15 years John's during that time
John served free terms as the mayor of
Broadstairs and some Peters in 1999 2000
and 2005 2008 sadly he's in his second
term in 2006 unfortunately John lost his
wife Sheila who was also an elected town
councilor and they're very active firm
team together despite suffering a stroke
in 2008 John continued to be very active
within the Broadstairs and some Peters
twit twinning Association and was a
regular visitor to what in a our twin
town just outside Lille I will remember
with some embarrassment when council
amazed Saunders and I were part of the
organising committee for the Broadstairs
water dollar and responsible for
producing the souvenir program and
having produced 2,000 copies it was
pointed out that we had printed John's
surname incorrectly we printed it
Fullerton not Fullerton John took it in
good heart took us to one side and
explained in his Scottish accent the
difference between the English spelling
and the Scottish spelling and the
Scottish spelling was correct John has
been referred in local press as being a
unique character to which I concur
in his later years John moved to be
closer to his daughter and therefore we
lost contact to it with him but he was
very very active in Broadstairs and left
a lot of happy memories thank you thank
you very much indeed
David councillor Saunders does anyone
else have any words I did have the
privilege of knowing both men and of
course I shall miss them myself
moving on to agenda item 4 declarations
of interest are there any declarations
of interest from members this evening I
don't see any moving on to agenda item 5
petitions no petitions have been
received in accordance with council
procedure rule number 12
I now move on to agenda item six
questions from the press and public four
questions have been received from
members of the public in accordance with
council procedure rule number thirteen
however question sixty has been
withdrawn at the request of the
questioner please note that only the
questioner and respondent are permitted
to speak on the question and if the
questioner is not present at this
meeting their question cannot be put but
will be replied to in writing could the
questioner please only state the name of
the cabinet member to whom the question
is be put and read out the exact wording
of the question that they submitted to
the council would members please refer
to their supplementary agenda number one
moving straight on to agenda item 6a
question number one from a member of the
public regarding renewable energy I'm
pleased to welcome mr. Preston to the
meeting could you please make your way
to the top table mr. president
so good evening everybody my question is
to counsel that David Saunders and the
question is as follows in view of the
clear benefits of solar and air source
heat pumps in reducing co2 and advancing
climate change mitigation and reducing
energy costs for council run public
buildings long term rule TDC create a
clear strategy to install renewables on
all council buildings if not why not
Thank You mr. president
I call upon councillor David Saunders to
respond Thank You chairman the question
I can confirm that the current corporate
portfolio reviews includes a
consideration of the energy rating of
the properties the strategy is to reduce
the amount of property over a reasonable
period of time to ensure that the
council only keeps sustainable
properties some of the retained
properties will however be protected
through planning policy AG grade 2
listed and this may limit adaptations
therefore is not possible to apply this
request as a single policy at this stage
but as part of the revised asset
strategy
the council's commitment to
sustainability will be updated although
the question is about public buildings
mr. Preston may also like to know that
the council is also investing in energy
efficiency and renewable energy in
council housing over the past three
years we have spent in excess of 1
million pounds improving the energy
efficiency of homes including installing
double glazing and modern energy
efficient boilers and upgrading thermal
insulation we are investing in solar
panels as part of our new build program
installing twenty three point six kilo
watts of solar panel systems which will
result in a reduction of approximately
fifty thousand kilogram of carbon over a
five-year period and an annual
electricity
raishin of 18,000 202 kilowatts of
renewable electricity we also we are
also working to improve energy
efficiency of the district's wider
housing stock strategic priority four of
our draft local plan sets out our
commitment to ensuring that all new
development is built to the highest
attainable quality and sustainability
standards we have also adapted a new
housing assistance policy grant aimed at
improving the energy efficiency of
private sector homes occupied by
vulnerable residents Thank You
councillor Saunders councillor thank you
very much mr. president
moving on to agenda item 6b question
number 2 from a member of the public
regarding the overview and scrutiny
panel and pleased to welcome miss Austin
to the meeting could you please make
your way to the top table is awesome
good evening my question is to
councillor pew CDC's website states that
the function of the overview and
scrutiny committee is to monitor the
performance of the leader and cabinet
and scrutinize services and policies
throughout the district
how can it do this effectively if
information can be withheld from it on
the basis of commercial confidentiality
or indeed on any other basis thank you
very much miss Austin I call upon
councilor pew to respond
Thank You chair and thank you miss
Austin for your question information
which is rep which is relevant to the
work of the ODU in scrutiny panel would
not generally be withheld from the panel
on the grounds of commercial
confidentiality where such information
is relevant to the work of the panel
officers would recommend that it is
dealt with after the exclusion of the
press and the public where the
information belongs to a third party we
would seek the views of the third party
on how the information could be shared
with thank Thank You councillor Pugh
thank you miss Austin I move on to
agenda item 6c question number three
from a member of the public regarding
the Ramsgate port feasibility study I'm
pleased to welcome mr. Murphy to the
meeting could you please make your way
to the top table mr. Murphy thank you
good evening my question is for
councilor Beaufort evaluation criteria
in the port in the port Ramsgate
feasibility study tender favored low
price / quality and and encompass
unacceptably small operations with low
credit ratings quality analysis of all
options is vital to turn the port around
a low quality applicant may win what
will you do to stop this Thank You mr.
Murphy I call upon the leader to respond
Thank You chairman
and Thank You mr. Murphy for your
question the evaluation criteria for
this work has been written to suit the
value range and a specific content of
the project the project has a limited
budget so cost is an important factor
this does not mean however the quality
is not important and the quality score
still has a significant influence on the
outcome the contract also includes
provisions to protect the guyst
abnormally low or high bids and
protection in the event that the quality
element does not meet an acceptable
standard rules on a bidders credit score
are applied in a manner consistent with
similar valued projects it should be
noted that it would be unfair to require
prospective bidders to have a turnover
in excess of that suggested by the
council's procurement guidelines for
projects of this scale thank you very
much indeed counsel David Thank You mr.
mutt Thank You mr. Murphy
agenda item 60 as previously advised has
been withdrawn may question withdrawn
agenda item 7 now questions from members
of the council ten questions have been
received from members of the council
this evening please note that the time
allowed for consideration of questions
from members shall not exceed 30 minutes
I ask members to be as succinct as
possible if we don't have time for all
questions written answers will be
provided thank you so moving on to
therefore agenda item 7a question number
1 from a member regard
Brod says play areas I call upon
counselor gana thank you my question yet
Akash be plants replacer for playgrounds
in Broadstairs parks along with the
relevant section 106 funding for them
have been waiting for approval since
last year can you please confirm when
the new for playgrounds in four parts
will be installed thank you thank you
very much councillor Gardner I call long
councillor Ashby to respond to advise
that program has been drafted for the
playground refurbishment works scoping
work is being carried out to inform
tender documentation so the opportunity
can be advertised early in 2020
completion of the site work is
programmed for the end of June 2020
Thank You councillor Ashby councillor
garner do you have a supplementary
question yes please just one quick one
thank you very much the update I'm sort
of residents around those playgrounds
we'd be happy about that
one of the parks is in Mott in pop
mostly in my ward in some Peters at the
old Northwood path Vincent clothes Park
and the number of the residents they're
obviously keen for this to be done and
they're also quite keen Trevor to review
and help with the plans for the
playground would and I'm sure residents
around the other three would be the same
would it be possible please for them to
be engaged quite early on to get some
buy-in and what goes Thank You
councillor ash peers anything that you
can take up on yes I'll be delighted to
come along and we arranged a meeting
maybe with all all groups so we can
bring along the the planners from our
site from the officer side as well Thank
You councillor Ashby agenda item 7b
question number two from a member
regarding Tivoli woods
I call upon councillor Gregory
Thank You chairman this is a question
counselor counselor Ashby referencing
CDC's open space strategy 2018 that
sites health benefits and pollution
reduction evidence please explain the
tree and Wildlife decimation in Tivoli
woods since TBC so this covenant insight
will TDC designate the site a local
green space as it is demonstrably
special to the local community Thank You
councillor Gregory councillor Ashby can
you respond please
Thank You chair Thank You the proposals
for local green space that are put
forward by the community any proposal
would be considered under the criteria
for the local green space set out in the
national planning policy framework in
PPA the next opportunity to consider
proposals for local green space would be
during the review of the council's local
plan in 2020 or as part of any work to
develop a Margate neighbourhood plan in
the meantime the site is in question is
covered by historic tree preservation
order TPO from 1952 covering an area
which is formerly part of the old
railway line our planning enforcement
team has investigated the removal of the
trees on the whole site over the past
year these trees were not covered by the
tpo on the site and we referred the
matter to the Forestry Commission due to
the number of trees being removed
we have also protected 15 sycamore trees
on the frontage of this site by serving
and confirming a TPO earlier this year
we will continue to monitor the site to
ensure no unauthorized work occurs on
the protected trees you may choose to
put forward a proposal for the site to
be designated as a local green space
during the 2020 review of the council's
local plan demonstrating there is a
community sport support for this and I
am more than willing to help with that
project if you decide that that wouldn't
be the way you should go forward Thank
You councillor ashbey canister Gregory
do you have a supplementary care to ask
yes
symmetric question given the importance
to adhere to tea DC's climate emergency
declaration will you be seeking to
adjust the terms of sale of this land
that has a restrictive covenant whereby
a breach of such a document should
ensure any offending work is undone
Thank You councillor Gregory councillor
Ashby is anything you can offer here I'm
afraid I'd have to consult with the
estates Department on this this is not a
matter that obviously I covered under my
research under this question but I can
certainly come come back to you in
writing in due course Thank You
councillor Ashby
agenda item 7c question number three
from a member regarding the removal of
bins I call upon councillor era Thank
You chair and my question to councillor
SB Ramsgate residents have brought to my
attention the removal of dog waste and
litter bins from our open spaces and
residential places people are having to
walk further to find bins and dog poo
bags may be discarded forever
what can the cabinet member tell me
about this Thank You councillor Ashby
you are in the wors tonight would you
care to respond Thank You chair haven't
been this popular since I won the
lottery I think it was a tenner litter
and dog poo bins have been removed in
King King George the sixth part Western
under cliff and the wear rec which have
been replaced with larger bins in
strategic locations at these sites we do
not have evidence at this stage there
has been a change in behave this has
changed behavior negatively rather than
to encourage people to take better
responsibility of their waste which they
are generating themselves and bringing
into our open spaces there are bins at
access and egress points of these sites
which may mean that some local some
location at some locations people may
have to walk a little further with their
waste to reach our bin than previously
but this will be a matter of minutes
which we feel is reason
dog ways can be put in any litter bins
stickers are available to be placed on
bins to reduce any confusion over this
if anybody feels that there are bins in
their area that people do not understand
that they can put dog waste in into a
general bin there are more than happy to
arrange for some stickers to go out if
you give me the locations of those
things Thank You councillor Ashby cancer
era have you got a supplementary yes
chair I had I did a little bit of
Investigation councillor SB the dog
workers across tenet especially in Kings
Georgia Stix Park seventeen bins were
removed and only three bins put in place
to replace for an 8.5 a coal and
Ellington Park has had a similar problem
as have other perhaps across valid
Ramsgate Thomas Center facing huge
problem with litter due to removal of
beans a Granger resident stated that a
bin had been removed from the co-op area
and not replaced and it seems the
pattern continues along the road and the
other areas in regards to dog waste
litter which people having to walk
further to beans or dog poo back la Ora
have you got a question here it sounds a
bit like a statement
well this this can cause blindness as
well as environmental hazard can the
cabinet assure me that the bins can be
added to the location that are clearly
lacking Thank You councillor ashpit you
wish to pick up on some of that if some
qualification sorry was he looked at a
program to try and facilitate the exits
and negresses of entry points at some of
the major sites I'm more than happy to
go and have a have a revisit and have a
look to see whether this is evidence I
actually am a dog walker and we have
points at various points but responsible
dog on this should be collecting the dog
waste and then carrying it with them
until they find a suitable place to
actually deposit the dog waste so but
I'm more than happy if you point out the
main sites that you're referring to I
think
down and have a look to see whether or
not and maybe you have a chat with the
dog walkers to see whether there is a
need for an extra facility Thank You
councillor Ashby would members please
refer to supplementary agenda number one
four remaining questions from members I
move straight on to agenda item 7d
question number four from a member
regarding fly-tipping I call upon
councillor Duckworth thank you sure has
any analysis has been done of the
effects of Kent County Council's
decision to start charging for tip use
to see a fly-tipping has increased since
the charges were introduced thank you
very much indeed
councillor Ashby operational services
are starting to gather information
regarding the regarding this since the
change was made recently implemented to
report back to KCC on any patterns or
impact found TVC are part of the Kent
resource partnership and attend a street
scene project group where these issues
are discussed in terms of dump rubble
there was a spiked increase in July and
this has since returned to more average
figures we will need a few more months
of charges to establish any long term
impact which by the way of work of the
Krays business partnership so it can say
as it is so important so we will be
keeping a close watch and this and as I
say that the Kent resource partnership
will be monitoring it very closely Thank
You councillor Ashby cancer Duckworth do
you have a supplementary I don't that
was very fun so that's Lesley fine thank
you well decorations council Ashby
agenda item 7e question number five from
a member regarding the system of
governance I can't call upon councillor
Bailey thank you caps rush we can have a
rest now
it's like this one's for the leader
three months ago this council passed a
motion
to explore the change of a system to a
cabinets as a committee system sorry my
understanding is that a new system of
governance can only be adopted once a
year at the annual council meeting in
May and unless unless I've missed
something we've yet to make a stop on
this work and I do know how slow the
wheels and FERC Governance turn and I'm
not sure if I'm being unrealistic
thinking that we might hit next May but
my question to the leader is in July a
motion was put forward for members to
explore the committee system of
governance has any work being done
towards this yet thank you Thank You
councillor baler councillor Burfoot yeah
thank chairman thank you counts debate
if you a question and you're absolutely
right on the 11th of July accounts we'll
greet the following motion the council
calls upon the four political groups and
the single non-aligned councillor I
think is yourself to work together to
identify preferred options for changing
our system of governance from the
current cabinet led system to a
committee led system and then submit
those options to the constitutional
review Working Party for consideration
now in researching this question it
appears that officers I think reasonably
have interpreted that this is a member
late process and yes it's fair to say
that nothing has happened so far so the
only thing that I can suggest is that
perhaps you and I could make afterwards
and look at how we might actually set
the wheels in motion for this Thank You
councillor Byford councillor begley do
you have a supplementary well I did but
that's comes quite surprised to me I
have been reading somewhere recently an
article by a instead ed Hammond of the
Centre for public scrutiny who who says
that since the May elections more and
more councils are changing to a
committee system and he is offering to
help councils to consider their options
as an independent and neutral broker so
I just wondered if this might be
something that our counts will be
interested in taking up
Thank You counselor via cancer paper do
you want to follow up on that I don't
see how got anything to add I'm in
casterbridge I think you know if you and
I get together and work out how we think
we might be able to bring something
forward I think that would be best my
four words and if that involves outside
help if there was any budget for that
thank you thank you very much councillor
Baffert agenda item 7f question number 6
from a member regarding travelers
I call upon councillor Roth Thank You
chair my question is for council again
this council has legal moral duty to
work people of nomadic habit in 2012 the
nationally agreed immediate need for a
need-need peach for 600 less than a
third of those has been provided do we
do we provide peaches with basic hygiene
services sufficient to the need of these
minority in your area thank you thank
you for that I call upon councillor game
to respond thank you for your question I
hope you don't mean 6,000 in sonnet I've
got 6,000 here yes actually it does say
6,000 on the question yes right okay
the primary requirement to assess gypsy
and traveler accommodation needs is set
out in the housing and Planning Act 2016
section 1 2 4 government guidance is in
the planning policy for traveler sites
the Department for Communities and Local
Government 2015 the council has been
involved in a series of studies with the
previous one being undertaken in 2014
which identified no need in the district
the most recent study fourth on it was
part of a suite of such studies
undertaken across Kent to provide
up-to-date evidence and was published in
March 2019
the study identified a need of seven
permanent [ __ ] and five transit
pitches over the planned period - to
that 2031 the council's current draft
local plan includes the policy setting
out how any applications for sites will
be assessed and determined the council
is due to review its local plan
following adoption in 2020 and will take
proactive steps to accommodate all
emerging needs of Gypsy and traveling
communities within the district whilst
there are currently not any sites within
SONET the council has established a
scrutiny review group which is currently
exploring site options for this
provision and an update is due at the
November scrutiny meeting thank you
thank you very much Chancellor Kane
councillor Roth do you have a
supplementary question thank you when
member of this minority group get ill or
or no longer can travel will be left
behind what this council plan to ensure
the safety and health well-being of
these minority thank you very much
counselor came are you able to respond
to that yes our community safety team
take the health and well-being of the
travelers into great great seriousness
and what they actually do is they
actually visit the travelers and they
they have a medical team with them at
now and sure the travelers are fit and
healthy before they would try and move
them on thank you thank you thank you
very much indeed for that councillor
game agenda item 7 G question number 7
from a member regarding Ramsgate port
I call upon councillor wing Thank You
chair given the TDC contract we Brits
makes the landlord TDC responsible for
maintaining and or upgrading the
facilities they use at the port of
Ramsgate half brits
ever requested work to be carried out
and did this include the proposed work
involving one of the one of
pontoons presently at the Ramsgate in
Ramsgate harbour thank you very much
indeed councillor wing because the
Beaufort thanks emmalin Thank You
councillor wing the council is obliged
to repair or renew berth for five the
stated in the facilities agreement the
agreement does not specify the method of
construction for the berth fixed key or
floating pontoon berth Brett continued
to require the use of a berth as
indicated in the agreement thank you
very much indeed counselor be forecaster
winger because of supplementary well I'm
not quite sure what questions been
answered because I think it was a close
question yes or no to where the Brits
have requested any work to be done to
the facilities that we have to upgrade
or maintain I'm not sure that's a
question counselor Beaufort but would
you have anything more you'd like to say
on that a yes/no answer is required I
think the answer we know yeah we have it
agenda item 7 H do I get my
supplementary now councillor winger you
just had the opportunity of it and you
seem to passed on it
I'm afraid I'm sorry I'm afraid I'm
going to move on agenda item 7 age
question number 8 from a member
regarding the council becoming carbon
neutral I call upon councilor oppa Paula
Paula Saunders to answer this question
please whilst we wait for the climate
emergency working party to be formed
could relevant council officers please
examine ways in which TDC could move
forward to becoming carbon neutral for
example ensuring that our electricity
supply comes from in uribl sources and
that any vehicle replacements are
environmentally friendly as possible
thank you thank you very much indeed
Kelly Roper councillor David Saunders
Thank You councillor Roper as part of
this question was answered in
the public question from mr. press 'land
but again I can confirm that the
corporate portfolio review which we're
currently doing members may realize that
we have quite an extensive portfolio of
properties and we're scrutinizing all of
the properties we have and you will find
over the coming months that more
properties will be brought to this
council as part of the asset disposal
program and I say again that the
properties that we're looking to retain
are the properties that we can adapt and
improve sustainability with regards to
vehicles we're also looking at vehicles
we do have issues with regards to the
fleet that we run particularly with the
large freighters for the waste disposal
and we are taking consideration for
electric vehicles we're also looking at
increased electrical electrical points
around the town and around the district
and the smaller vehicles I'm sure once
we come to a situation where we need to
replace them
we will seriously consider electric
Thank You councillor Saunders councillor
Roper do you have a supplementary yes
just to say that it's looking
increasingly likely we're going to take
on our own housing so if that happens
and I do hope that we will examine very
carefully every single council house to
see if we can make it as environmentally
friendly as possible to reduce the
carbon footprint is that the case
basically thank you thank you counselor
counselor Saunders I can't really answer
that question because we've made no
decisions with regards to our housing
and that's still under consideration but
should your proposition come to fruition
yes indeed that's the sort of thing that
we will be looking at thank you
Thank You councillor Saunders agenda
item 7 aye
question number 9 from a member
regarding the protection and planting of
trees I Paul upon councillor Ference
this is a question for council rash B it
has been clearly stated that
scientifically planting more trees is
the biggest and cheapest way to tackle
the climate crisis GDC unanimously
declared a climate emergency on the 11th
of July so what action is the council
taking to plant more trees in Fannett as
well as safeguarding our existing trees
Thank You councillor Farrington
councillor Ashby I remember your
portfolio thank you for your question
this will be encompassed in the overall
response to climate emergency
declaration through the Working Party
being formed actions may include looking
to plant more trees in Japan as well as
safeguarding our existing trees the role
of the arborist is currently being
recruited and this officer will play a
key part in the management of our trees
and open spaces other projects are being
explored where the council can for
example some support communities when
applying for funds to plant more trees
however I personally have been working
as in apartment as a partner in the Isle
of Thanet tree and woodland initiative
it we as that's a bit of a mouth for I
decided to abbreviate it with a view to
planting a large number of trees across
sites in fact at this stage nothing has
been finalized but we are hoping for a
positive outcome Thank You councillor
ash because the Ference you have a
supplementary I just I'm interested
obviously that you are conducting a
program but I'm disappointed that as the
climate emergency was declared on the
11th of July by this council that
nothing has happened as yet could I ask
you to be clear with a timeline perhaps
with the organisation shall win and keep
me updated
about how we're moving on this and also
about safeguarding existing trees I'm
not quite clear about how we're doing
that Thank You councillor Ashby thank
you I mean there are various approaches
being made to this I mean the arborist
role obviously will bring this all
together and this information all
together which hopefully as soon as they
are employed and they're bedded in then
they can come and give reports to
Council I know it's obviously a topic of
great interest to a lot of people I know
that councillor Pugh is working oh I
think I'm right in saying that part of
the the climate emergency team will be
building in a large part for the tree
provision are both existing and for
future plantings the initiative that
I've referred to is not actually a
council project it's something that I am
working on personally but it will bring
a great deal of benefit into this
district so and hopefully from that
project is successful then we can build
other projects around it if we are
successful thank you
Thank You councillor Ashby agenda item
7j question number 10 from a member
regarding shelter surveys
I call upon councillor whitehead thank
you very much chair good evening all
my question is to councillor Saunders
considering the recent works to both the
Fort Hill in Newgate gap shelters in the
interest of transparency could council
please outline for the public how a
section 78 notice is implemented and
identify which contractors have been or
will be used to assess the structural
integrity of these shelters thank you
very much
Thank You councillor weiter councillor
Saunders thank you for the question yes
a section 78 Building Act notice which
covers dangerous buildings and
structures allows the local authority to
demolish a dangerous or unsafe structure
without the need of a court order should
these properties and not be a belong to
the council then we've had to go through
a totally
separate process of notification etc etc
they do belong to us so in theory we
could demolish these without any any
court order
however there were hate health and
safety issues at both these shelters
we've had contractors on sites to err to
the best of our ability we've made both
sites safe we haven't got to the stage
where we need to or think we're going to
implement the section 78 notification
because both of the shelters are we're
looking at both shelters to be one is an
asset transfer to an interested groups
should they be interested and the Fort
Hill shelter has concrete cancer and
we're still assessing the safety of that
shelter although we had made it safe and
members will know that it's been boarded
up and I understand that a respective
artist a respected rather artist is
being commissioned to actually paint a
mural or something on those as part of
the Turner Prize year as far as the
contractors are concerned as I say one
is a metal structure the other one is a
concrete which has concrete cancer so
the specialist surveyors that we get as
time goes on will be specialists in
those two areas may be the same
specialist but I can't give you any
names at this stage once we do get to
that stage I'm quite happy to let you
know who the contractors are more
importantly who the contractors
subcontractors are thank you very much
Council Saunders very thorough
councillor whitehead you have a
supplementary I do thank you very much
for that response considering the
concerns of members of the public in
relation to the shelters could you tell
me if there is a mechanism whereby the
structural integrity put reports can be
a made available to the public
Thank You councillor Saunders caster
Saunders I believe the the steel
structure survey is in hand
I don't believe that we've commissioned
a survey at all on the faulty law we
simply made it safe and made it suitable
for this decoration but as soon as those
structures and those surveys are done
yes they will be available to members
thank you very much counselor Saunders
can I just say they'll also be available
to any interested groups that may wish
to take the shelters over very good
agenda item eight motions on notice one
motion on notice has been received in
accordance with council procedure rule
three agenda item 8a motional notice
regarding council housing I call once
again straight back in again councillor
Whitehead this council regards the
recently identified health and safety
failings in the management of ferrets
council housing by East Kent Housing
that's grossly unacceptable and a grave
failure of the council's duty of care
towards its tenants council also notes
concerns with regards to potential
financial matters mismanagement
consequently council has no confidence
in East Kent housing as an organization
and calls upon cabinet to take
substantive action during the current
calendar month towards bringing this
Authority's council housing back into
direct management should I speak to the
motion at this point or wait for
seconder
just hold on can we got a seconder for
your motion thank you very much I would
you like to speak to that now councillor
Whitehead thank you ready availability
of safe good quality housing is a
fundamental human right I believe that
everyone within this chamber
acknowledges and believes this our
responsibility towards our tenants is
paramount and is a duty that we are all
aware of and feel very strongly it is my
belief and the belief of the labor group
that the use of arms-length management
organizations undermines and dilutes
this responsibility our tenants are ours
to care for and to look after it is us
they look to to resolve their issues
both as councillors under the council
and their concerns and needs are best
addressed directly the performance of
East Kent Housing has to say the least
demonstrated the flaws in this model
very clearly the series of compliance
failings that left our tenants at risk
in terms of gas safety and electrical
safety checks alone illustrates the
dangers of abrogating responsibility in
this way due to our usage of an
arm's-length organization the regulator
for social housing judged us to be
non-compliant in relation to our duties
this is unacceptable and we have a clear
way forward it has always been the
Labour Party position that fundamental
services are best provided in house we
hold this position now and it is
heartening to see that as a council we
are now moving towards the adoption of
an in-house service providing high
quality direct services to residents who
deserve the very best from us other
councils are ahead of us with our mow
usage reducing by over half since 2010
alongside councillor Huxley and our head
of Housing Bob Porter this week I was
privileged enough to see the high
quality housing and long term planning
that we are more than capable of
providing as an area and I echo and
welcome mr. Porter's focus on a golden
thread of compliance property
development management and the ability
to build in environmental sustainability
to our housing stock are all skilled our
officers and workforce have and are
using to great effect
I call upon council and counselors here
present to support our residents our
tenants and our current position and
commit to helping the progress the
development of our in-house housing
management
thank you very much Council thank you
very much indeed councillor whitehead in
accordance with council procedure rule
3.7 a member of the controlling
political group is entitled to reply I
call upon councillor game
ah thank you for putting this fort it's
motion forward cants in a white hurt as
you are well aware we are all concerned
and I'd like to stress that the health
and safety of our tenants is of the
utmost importance I do hope that you
haven't brought this motion forward on a
political agenda I would hope that we
can all work together in a spirit of
cooperation you must more or less know
exactly what I'm going to say now
because we have regular meetings and
briefings with Bob Porter head of
housing and we share every single
document about Eastern housing with you
but I will say the failure of East Kent
housing to properly manage health and
safety in the council's housing stock is
completely unacceptable
the emergence of health and safety
failings of East Kent Housing this year
followed ongoing concerns about the
wider performance in East Kent housing
to the extent that the cabinet agreed an
improvement plan for East Kent housing
on the 15th of January 2019 and
additional resources to support
improvements were included in this
year's management fee for the service
progress against his plan has been
unacceptably slow as detailed in the
quarter one performance report
considered by the council's overview and
scrutiny panel on the 1st of October
2019 and which you have seen on the 25th
of July 2019 cabinet considered the
failures East Kent Housing in respect of
gas safety and other areas of health and
safety cabinet recorded wider concerns
about the services provided by East Kent
Housing and agreed to receive a further
report setting out the potential future
options for the management of the
council's housing stock that report
you've also seen this report will be
considered by cabinet at its meeting on
the 17th of October one week from today
where the Covenant cabinet will review
the potential options agreed preferred
future arrangements for the management
of the council's housing and agreed to
launch an immediate statutory
consultation with residents the letters
will go out literally the next day I
will continue to meet with you on a
monthly basis so that you are fully
briefed as you are now on progress thank
you thank you very much indeed
councillor game two members wish to
debate this motion we do who else would
like to speak then at this point
councillor Constantine I think you won't
be surprised to hear me say that I fully
support this motion and actually what a
disgrace that was that report that we
received and what a fragile tonight well
we've we've created for our for our
residents and I think it makes very good
sense to bring back in the workers back
into panic district councils control and
I'm sure that 2p will apply so there
won't be any job losses and I think
that's an excellent thing I would like
to think that once we take back the
housing into TDC control that we'll be
able to support the tenants robustly and
resource to create proper tenants
associations so our tenants have genuine
control and say and voice over the
housing stock that they live in and we
don't always get it right by any means
and this report has demonstrated that I
recently undertook an inspection of both
Kennedy house and trove court I did this
to look at fire hazards as when I sat on
the Kent and Medway Fire and Rescue
Authority I had a lot of complaints so I
took an opportunity to go and see for
myself and in doing that and I also had
a look at the general look and feel of
those buildings now what I saw was a
lack of lights not even light switches
in some of the public areas and there
were issues with the life shaft shafts
there were no ladders for access to the
light to the lift shaft sorry and one of
the lift shafts was actually completely
plastered over so I don't know how
anybody would get access to that lift
shaft in an emergency and the fire
systems lacked proper and adequate
signs the sign outside that was for
mustering in the events of a fire
breaking out was completely inadequate
you couldn't read it so there was
actually no signage on how to muster in
the event of a fire the signage inside
the building was woefully out of date
and in fact in one case for electricity
electricity supply it said to contact
seaboard electricity and obviously
that's not been in play I think since
the 1990s and so really I thought it was
in very poor state of repair and
condition generally speaking and the
other thing that was very lacking was
the lack of any sort of community
noticeboards so it didn't seem to have a
community feel at all so I thought that
was really wrong so I hope that when we
bring this back into house these are the
sort of issues we can fix and create
proper amenities for people and last but
not least it would be remiss of me not
to mention the fire hazards and the
risks currently associated with the
family of eight living in a tent on this
council's watch a family of eight still
living in a tent I think we're up to
about 10 or 11 weeks now so I support
this motion Thank You Connor councillor
Constantine councillor Piper did you
indicate Thank You chairman we'd like to
support this motion as well
wholeheartedly it is obvious to those of
us who've been around even just for
three or four years that this has been a
problem that's been coming and was going
to hit hard when it got here I might
mention that former councillor Suzanne
bream who was a feisty character indeed
was all over this and we know what
happened when she started to raise
issues it is very important that jobs
are protected as well but most of all
bringing the care much closer to home
and I believe on a slightly wider matter
it was one of the things that gave many
of us real concerns about ek force drug
v was that the movement of the
protection of our people and our
responsibilities was getting further and
further away
we've got to have some changes in the
direction of whatever it might be called
but this would seem to me to be a very
positive movement bring it back in house
as soon as we can with all the legal
niceties that have got to be followed so
we would wholeheartedly support the
motion Thank You councillor Piper
councillor Everett Thank You chair um
yeah I mean I saw detected that council
the game resented the motion being
bought as if there's some sort of
political stunt I just like to say to
council again really we haven't directed
this motion as a personal criticism of
you or or all of the cabinet because we
recognize that the whole problem with
the model of East Kent housing is that
you can't exercise your oversight
responsibilities properly under it
that's the that's the whole issue and I
think it also leaves our chief executive
exposed in a position of legal
responsibility that is completely
unrealistic um but going back to when
this came in let's be honest about this
this was a political decision and it
divided this council politically the
labor group opposed to setting up of
these Kenneth E skin housing now we were
right and we don't take any great
satisfaction in that for political
reasons because it's been a burden on
our residents it hasn't served our
residents properly there is something
about the word arm's length organization
which I really don't like and I think it
implies something held at a distance
within dystonia and we really have to
adopt an attitude which says that our
council housing and our council tenants
are absolutely fundamental to what this
council does and I hope when we bring
the service back in-house they will be
able to look to counselors to help them
with their problems and we'll be able to
get answers from officers because they
are accountable inside this council
that's the change we want to make and I
hope that all members in future will be
able to be proud of this council's
council housing service and that the
cabinet will move swiftly to deliver
that thank you very much councillor
Everett I move to the leader councillor
BAE furred yeah Thank You chairman I'm
gonna the first thing to say is that as
Casa dam had already said I mean
everybody's pushing at an open door here
we have got rapport going to cabinet
that suggests that we were looking to
bring council housing back under our
direct control I think though when
council Constantine taught us about you
notice is shaded I think we should also
recognize though it will be the tenants
decision that they want to come back in
so I don't think we should assume I mean
I suspect they will want to come in but
you know let's make sure that we do it
the right way cancer cancer Everett is
right I mean the setting up of the the
Alamo was something that politically
divided the council but at the time
there were an awful lot of counts
councils that were going down these kind
of setups and they did seem to be kind
of flavor of the month
and they did seem to offer a way of
providing a more efficient more
effective hours in service certainly
wasn't the objective when it was set up
the counter was a abdicating
responsibility far from it but I would
agree with him that I think that what
has happened over the years is that the
oversight by the councils that are
involved in this has become perhaps more
and more remotes and there has been an
expectation that East Kent housing would
be fulfilling their responsibilities to
the utmost ability and that doesn't seem
as though it's happened but going back
to the original point I mean you've seen
the the reports going to cabinet we are
recommending that we go out to to
consultation with residents and this
place though they'd like to come back in
then that's what we do as quickly as
possible thank you thank you very much
councillor David I saw your arm in the
air counter Campbell very much chair
yeah just one quick point I just like to
commend the work of East Kent Aldi
partnership miss partners Parker's team
correctly discovering the failings of
East Kent housing in this respect and if
members would like to see the litany of
failures if they look at the agenda item
for governance audit on the 25th of
September pages 17 to 19 there's they're
actually all included there thank you
Jeff
thank you very much in T canceler
Campbell councillor Whitehead would you
like to wind up thank you very much
I would like to thank everybody who
chose to contribute to this debate I'd
like to thank counselor Dame for her
very thorough response I would also like
to make it clear that I never make
points for a political reason I am very
very interested in policy I'm not
particularly interested in politics in
that sense and I would like counsel to
recognize that this is our public forum
this is the perfect place for us to show
our tenants our residents exactly how we
feel and what we intend to do and that
is my exact reason for bringing this
this is where we show how much we care
how concerned we are and what we can do
to change the situation thank you again
to everyone excellent thank you very
much indeed councillor White's hit it
can I can I ask therefore do we agree
the motion this evening
agreed thank you very much indeed agenda
item 9 the leaders report I call upon
the leader
thanks Jay I'm pleased to announce that
Flajnik District Council has been
successful in its bid for Ramsgate to be
selected as a high streets Heritage
Auctions I'm the hearse house apparently
a scheme funded by historic England the
application which was submitted by this
council with support from local partners
including the coastal community team in
Ramsgate Town Council we see them
working with historic England together
these organizations will develop and
then deliver a four year program of
physical improvements community
engagement and cultural activities the
specific aim is to help regenerate and
Ramsgate High Street and the scheme will
help us to restore the unique character
of Harper Street and the high street
improving the area for those that live
in the town and attracting new
businesses and footfall high streets are
shown to bring value to a location
acting as a center for local commerce
and the local community so we look
forward to working with historic England
to develop the program design and to
build on the good work of the existing
heritage actions on Ramsgate was also
recently confirmed as going through to
the second stage of the future high
streets and which is successful will
complement this scheme
focusing on access to the area movement
of traffic and occupy occupancy and use
of buildings the Ministry of housing
communities and local government has
announced the welcome news that Margate
has been selected as one of the hundred
towns in England that will be supported
to develop one of the new town deals
this funding has the potential to help
improve broadband connectivity
infrastructure create vital local social
and cultural places that bring people
together as well as boosting jobs and
economic growth with up to 25 million
pounds of investment potentially
available this funding could totally
transform Margay delivering transit or
long-term benefits to the town and
greatly improving the prospects of local
people we see this as a fantastic
opportunity to further revitalize the
town and look forward to work and
working with the local community who
will have a significant say in how we
achieve that we look forward to hearing
more about the scheme and working with
public sector business and community
stakeholders to work up their proposals
it's important for the council to know
what residents think about their area
and their services given a significant
reduction in funding from government and
increasing pressure on local councils
with CDC receiving just 14 pence in
every pound of council tax we want to be
sure that we're dealing with the issue
issues that matter most the residents
each year we conduct a resident survey
which is sent at random to approximately
6000 residents across the district this
year survey will shortly be sent to a
random selection of residents and I'd
like to encourage everyone who receives
a survey to ensure that they take apart
I'm also delighted to confirm that the
fanuc Rhys team who worked with the
homeless who find themselves living on
our streets has been shortlisted in the
Kent Housing Group Excellence Awards in
the Team of the Year category this
multi-agency team has achieved so much
since their inception last year and is
making a real impact on the lives of
some of the most vulnerable in our
district
the award ceremony takes place at the
end of October so we hope to report even
more positive news imminently until
perhaps less good news
we are hitting small 31st of October and
brixey and CDC has been working to
identify the potential impact to bricks
it on the services that we deliver and
on the wider fanuc district we now have
contingency plans in place to manage any
potential disruption to the provision of
services to the local community the most
immediate potential impact for Thanet
area will be the use of Matson airfield
site as part of the national government
contingency plans to relieve pressure on
the m20 now advise the residents would
be this is advice to myself actually
because I find myself in a strange
position that I will be traveling to New
Haven on October the 31st and hopefully
to France on November the 1st whether I
make it back is another question but I
know that lots of people would actually
welcome that javelina
but what we're advising residents is to
check before you travel to ensure that
you can complete your journey allow
extra travel time and consider
alternative routes if using public
transport check for any changes to the
service ensure that you take extra food
and water any prescription medication
that may be needed in the event of your
journey being delayed over the past 12
months the council has actively engaged
with all relevant partners through the
Kent resilience forum at a strategic and
tactical level in preparation for the UK
leaving the EU at the end of the month
each council service area has carried
out a business continuity impact
assessment which will ensure that the
necessary plans are in place to continue
the delivery of council services the
council has also assigned a brexit lead
who is overseeing the range of
activities required to ensure that all
our preparation efforts are on track and
welcomed or coordinated I'd just like to
add my little bit sir all the interest
in their shelters give an update you go
get a recent repair work at the new gate
gap shelter and Margaret was carried out
in the interest of Public Safety it's on
our community asset transfer list and
expressions of interest have already
been received which is encouraging news
the deadline in fact was yesterday so
the structure will also be subject to an
independent evaluation commission but
then it's council to assess any further
steps
ahead of an athletic transfer process as
France Fort Hill shelters concerned
remedial work was carried out to make it
safe following a section 78 notice the
organizers organizers of Margate now are
actually going to display artwork on the
holdings in celebration in the Turner
Prize coming to Margate and following
the Turner Prize exhibition an
independent assessment will take place
to inform future options and ensure due
process is followed I thought made the
point before that I have to write this
leaders report significantly in advance
of this meeting so therefore it does
contain duplication but I make no
apologies as a Titan the trouble to
write it I'm going to read out right to
say about East Kent housing and I'm sure
that everyone in this chamber will agree
that the failures that have emerged this
year in the management of resident
health and safety very scant housing are
completely unacceptable
these failures have placed their
residents at risk and cannot be
tolerated in any circumstances the
council has responded promptly to these
issues and is working with the regulator
for social housing and with specialists
the external advisors to recover the
position as quickly as possible
additional resources had been provided
focused on completing urgent actions an
interim security and inspection regimes
have been implemented to reduce any
risks identified cabinet considered the
position at this meeting in July an
instructed urgent work to assess
alternative options to East Kent housing
for the future management of our housing
stock this work is complete and cabinet
will consider reported its meeting next
week the report will recommend that the
council's preferred options should be to
bring the management of the councillors
housing stock back in the house and it
should start an immediate consultation
with residents regarding this proposal
I'm also able to report some positive
progress as a result of the
interventions as the East Kent Audit
partnership has reviewed the position in
relation to gas safety and concluded
that there is no substantial assurance
in relation to the management of gas
safety that said there remains work to
do and we will continue to give this the
highest priority until the same can be
confirmed for all areas of Health and
Safety Mountain
finally we've just welcomed the Turner
Prize to Margate and I'm really grateful
to all of those who helped to ensure the
area's booking at its best for such a
momentous occasion it's an amazing
moment for thinik the district is one of
the most vibrant art scenes in the UK
and hosting this prestigious prize
strengthens markets reputation as a
cultural powerhouse Turner was a regular
visitor producing a number of works of
the seaside town and declaring that the
skies over Thanet are the loveliest in
all Europe so it really feels like the
prize is coming home turn the
contemporary welcome nearly 10,000
people to the gallery this weekend
making it their best autumn opening on
record in spite of the weather and we're
confident that this will present a real
opportunity to the whole district what
is in the cultural and artistic
spotlight for the duration of the
exhibition and beyond thank you thank
you very much indeed councillor Baffert
and you know he told me earlier this
evening he didn't think he'd have so
much to say tonight councillor Everett
would you like a comment or ask
questions in relation to the leaders
report ceiling oh my wallet oh yeah yes
I associate myself with councillor by
Ford's comments about the Turner Prize
and the positive impact on mark either
that's bringing and obviously we welcome
that as far as Ramsgate and the high
streets heritage action zone founded by
historic England is concerned obviously
very good news for the council I think
that most people in on the council new
planet believe that West will cross has
been a big success as a shopping centre
and a facility of the residence but
there's no doubt that it has had an
impact on our high streets in all the
towns and I think especially in Ramsgate
Margate and what concerns me is that the
identity of Fanny is very much provided
by the towns it isn't provided by West
will cross so it's obviously important
that we maintain these as vibrant places
to live shop visit and work council
paper did did refer to Ramsgate Town
Council but I mean I want to
particularly highlight the contribution
that has been made to the regeneration
around trade by the Ramsgate town team
and the Tampa motor funded by Ramsgate
Town Council because I think they give a
real focus to the efforts to improve the
town one of the items later on the
agenda
that makes sense the council's support
from our gay town council I do
personally think that Margate would
benefit from having a high sign elected
voice although I do come from the other
side of the Oilers most people know I
just wonder if the leader might be a bit
more enthusiastic about Ramsgate Town
Council
you might encourage the people of
Margate to decide to have one of their
own because I do sense occasionally that
there isn't that much enthusiasm on the
other side but I'd imagine while that
would be of course more gates also set
to benefit from the from the new towns
man up to 25 million potentially
available that's good news I'm a bit
suspicious about funding pots announced
by a central government because I think
governments of all stripes are more
interested in making announcements and
they are in actually delivering the
money there is a possibility that we
could be on the edge of an economic
precipice so I do hope that this money
will be delivered and that Margate will
benefit from it I'm not going to talk
about brexit or at least not very much I
will only say that in my talks with
discussions with senior officers I have
been impressed by the amount of
preparation that the council has done
and the work that it's done and it's the
efforts that it's gone to defend Fanny
and what fanuc needs
against perhaps other agencies that
won't be visible to residents and I mean
let's hope that it never becomes visible
because these contingencies don't arise
and we don't have the problems but we
also pay tribute to the work that's been
done I'm in terms of the annual resident
survey yes we have to do that we should
do it but any member of this council
knows that the state of our streets the
reliability of the refuse and recycling
collection and the cutting of the grass
is very high up residents list of
priorities we don't need a survey in
order to discover that there are real
challenges around this and as I said
that overview and scrutiny and when we
are focusing on the areas that the
tourists visit and we surround most
public and high-profile areas we mustn't
forget that the vanora T of residents do
not need near the beaches I can only
report back from my ward and I look at
the level of detritus and
in Newington road a mountain road and
other parts of Newington and it's
absolutely disgusting and I'm not saying
that Newington is an exception in that
respect I'm sure other members in
particular wards would have those issues
but we really need to focus on how we
can find the resources to address those
issues because residents have got their
part to play they may they may be among
those dropping the litter visitors may
be dropping the list at the refuse
collection may not be may not be
entirely satisfactory I don't think that
they're leaving the accumulated soil in
the gutter I think that's because the
council doesn't have a proper schedule
to clean those routes so that's
something that I'd like to see brought
forward and other members will have
concerns in other areas a bit surprised
caster Baker didn't mention the pulp
tonight I just want to say something
about that which is that I think the
council's communication and I have
expressed this beautiful to the leader
of what is going on what has gone on and
what's going to go on could be a lot
better at overview and scrutiny we asked
to see the legal advice which had led to
the purchase or the proposed purchase of
the pontoons I think it's only right
that I say in a public forum that I had
seen that advice and it does give me a
level of Ashe Lawrence about the
legality of the council's actions I
believe what I should put that on the
record I'm in the end these decisions
are taken by the administration that's
your job but we will not on this side
add to the rumors and speculation that
the council is doing things wrong thank
you very much indeed for that councillor
Everett that was very positive indeed
councillor BAE foot would you like to
respond yeah thank you chairman and
thank you councillor every because I do
think and in there there are lot of
sentiments that I welcome of course
you're right that Westwood cross has
been hugely successful has impacted on
town centres but I've always been a
proponent of a town council in Margate I
think that it would serve the town
really well if it had won and we've seen
yes Ramsgate town towns
was done quite well but if it wants an
exemplar should look no further than
Broadstairs but which is a superb superb
Town Council which goes about its
business without actually attracting the
opprobrium that certain people in Bronco
Town Council's attract but there we are
area as far as brace is concerned I mean
yeah you're right we are really
conscious of the impact on fanny and
it's going to be worse than it will be
in many places and it's fair to say that
I think we've bombarded ministers with
letters actually outlining our plight
and the fact that we expect to see
something coming back to us you know to
make up for what we're gonna have to put
up with and and I actually think that
that may be one of the reasons why we
figured in the hundred towns for the
town deal because quite honestly that
came out that bolt out the blow I think
surprised us all we suddenly felt we're
on this list and we can apply for twenty
five million pounds so you know perhaps
some good might come out of the bad
you're right about eating our services
we do have to actually look across at
the whole of the island and make sure
that every resident gets a fair crack of
the whip I do think though that we are
being particularly pressurised at the
moment I mean it probably we've received
something like six million visitors this
year that was a hell of a strain on
services and that is concentrating on
say France and beaches and unfortunately
because they are so prominent you know
we have to make sure that we really do
give full attention today and I can
assure you that the last two cabinet C&T
meetings that we've held where focus
very much on actually looking at what's
required to provide improvements to our
service or indeed with the cuts in money
that's coming our way how to maintain
the services we've got within the fact
that we have so we're very aware of that
the gutters I think you need to address
that to KCC rather than than us there we
are
and yes I would agree that perhaps we do
need to look a little bit communications
red of course concerned we're going to
thank you for your words where that's
going to say thank you very much
thank you very much indeed constabie
fir'd councillor Piper would you like to
question the leader or make any comments
from what he's had to say this evening
Thank You chair of course be sharing the
good news whenever it comes in our
direction
I like cancer Everett was going to
comment on the town team and the
tampered motor at Ramsgate and I would
also want to include on that list former
councillor Lynn Fairbrass who did an
awful lot of work in Ramsgate and also
here in this place to try and make some
of that happen I hope with regard to the
funding coming in the direction of
Margate as far as I'm aware it's not
coming anywhere near us to spend so I
hope that those who do have to spend it
do so wisely for the benefit not only of
Margate but for those visitors who may
also travel around other parts of a
Fenny
and of course delighted with the
involvement of the work of Rhys the
fennek Rhys team the work that they've
been doing has been growing steadily in
fact quite rapidly considering some of
what they've had to deal with and we
would hold safty wholeheartedly support
the message of congratulations to them
for their work with regard to brexit
well I don't talk about that much either
I happen to think it may be a bit
difficult but then it will not just
survive it we will thrive because of it
and hopefully Dover and Canterbury
councils will as we expect cooperate
very well with us and at least 63.8%
sorry to be so specific at least sixty
three point eight percent of the
residents of Faneca voted to leave the
European Union will be very pleased when
we do each Kent housing clearly is a
serious issue it's been touched on
already in the variety of ways in here
it's a serious issue that needs serious
resolutions and we will obviously need
to be cross-party completely proactive
with their offices and bringing about a
very good resolution as soon as is
practically possible with the caveat as
the leader says that the it's what the
residents want
it is great that others have decided to
honor this area with the Turner Prize
coming to market anything brings good
news and visitors to this area to
improve our economy is obviously good
news and perhaps the best part of it is
that it's come from outside the area
thank you for your visit thank you very
much indeed councillor Piper lilies
would you like to respond to any of that
yeah thanks Geralyn Thank You Alison
Piper as far as a market money is
concerned it is our intention that we
will engage the community and
stakeholders of of every persuasion to
make sure that the money if we're
successful is used properly regarding
brexit
I hope the 63% will be patient when
they're not able to get back home when
they've gone to you know a New Haven or
France or somewhere like that and yeah
you're absolutely right turn the price
absolutely absolute gem for us thank you
thank you very much indeed leader
I call upon councillor Roper to comment
on or ask questions in relation to the
leaders report thank you very much heard
you gave a short report you said well
I'm gonna give a short report as well so
great news first of all about Ramsgate
High Street action zone and all our
concerns we wish you every success also
very encouraging to hear about Margate
benefiting from the Newtown fund and
look forward to seeing the benefits
there all we need now is a lot more
money for the rest of Thanet I went to
see the Turner Prize on Saturday and yes
it's absolutely marvelous and such a
prestigious event has been housed in
vanish this the exact exhibits I would
say were stimulating but I can't say
they were totally all my cup of tea
it's a
as for the East Kent housing failures I
do sincerely look forward to seeing that
brought it back into house so we can
control what's going to happen brexit
plans well done for preparing but my
only comment is I sincerely hope they
will never be needed not popular with
everyone on the scene however there have
been some problems recently the bog off
pontoons seem to have created quite a
bit of a fuss and that's a clear example
perhaps of where we could have done
better I would like to feel that as a
council and as offices we can be more
open we can have more open debate and we
can have more scrutiny with a more
effective communication system to both
members and to the public and I
sincerely hope that whatever happens the
councillors of all political stripes can
work together to try and improve this is
the services of planet and I
particularly can't wait to begin the
action on the climate emergency okay
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed pastor Roper I guess a beef oh
did you care to respond thank chairman
thank has arrived right I don't think
most that needs a response if it was
statement of how council Roper feels
about things and once of the openness
and scrutiny I mean I think I do my part
I think I've been at every scrutiny
meeting since the annual Council and
that there's a seat kept for me there so
I'm doing my bit castle refused all I
can say thank you very much indeed
councillor Bay furred remembers moving
on to agenda item 10 report of the
chairman of the over knew and scrutiny
panel now as members will be aware
councillor Campbell has resigned the
chairmanship of this committee and the
no and
no I don't think so we all like
counselor camel we were going to have a
report from the vice-chairman councillor
David part at Parsons this evening
unfortunately councillor Parsons has
been called away urgently nevertheless
council Campbell has stepped into the
breach and is going to say a few words
on behalf of the Ovilus Kootenay panel
Thank You councillor Campbell
thank you very much sure yes a popular
demand yes
as it's been exhibited earlier on apart
from the meetings in the agenda we also
met on the first of October to
scrutinize the port and harbor projects
the variations at 2019-20 capital
program for the potential purchase of
two pontoons basically the propulsion is
to the proposition I should say is to
relocate 590 came to the commercial
berth in the eastern galley leaving 897
K in the capital program to deliver the
replacement a burst four and five
external legal advice has been sought
and the members of the panel have been
given the opportunity as my leader that
whatever I said to you that advice
we also scrutinized East Kent housing
halter one performance report that's
been mentioned earlier on this evening
was Upton the chief executive he spent
housing was invited to attend and she
did in fair to say the performance of
East Canton housing is very very poor an
audit discovered that our limited
assurances for gas safety no assurance
for fire safety no assurance for
electrical safety no assurance for lists
and no assurance for Legionella miss
Upton agreed that there was a serious
breakdown in the management of tenant
safety at East Kent housing the cabinet
member Council again stated that
alternative options would be put forward
at the next cabinet meeting as she's
mentioned earlier at this evening thank
you very much thank you very much indeed
counter Campbell and no one would
believe he hadn't prepared himself for
that this evening thank you very much
members moving on to agenda item 11 the
corporate statement I call upon the
leader
yeah thank you chairman the Constitution
requires that the count
as corporate statement is adopted by for
counsel in accordance with budget and
policy framework procedure rules so I'm
recommending tonight the council note
the report and adopt the proposed new
corporate statement and supporting core
business objectives and I think this
report has become something of an old
friend really it was mentioned first the
cabinet on the 25th of July when I made
the point which I will make again that
this needs to be a whole council
document we need to be behind this
this actually outlines what we're going
to do in the four years that they're
ahead of us and took us it's starting
point in fact last couple of resident
surveys so hopefully what we're looking
to do actually meets with their approval
but as I said I mean it was important to
me that we got buy-in to this so that as
well as cabinet on the 25th
we had a members briefing on the 30th of
July where all members were entitled to
come along look at the proposals that
have been put forward and suggest
alternatives and amendments um we also
suggested it should go to our view
scrutiny which he did on the 27th of
August and what happened was that that
meeting by then we'd already adopted
some of the things that come out the
members briefing and then over in
scrutiny made further recommendations
which got incorporated into a cabinet
report on the 19th of September but even
at that light stage somebody proposed an
amendment I think it was yes and we
we've subsequently included that in the
reporters before you tonight so
hopefully we can without too much ado
adopt this and get on with the job thank
you
Thank You Council beefer do you have a
seconder for that counselor Ashby
councillor Everett you wanted to speak I
did and what I have to say is wholly
positive I'm being very nice to cows to
pay for this evening so far anyway what
I want you to say is you know Casa de
Beauford has said that this had to be a
health counselor document and they did
adopt a collaborative approach and the
labor group put forward a number of
recommendations overview and scrutiny
which reflects our political priorities
now manifesto and I have to say that
they have all been incorporated into the
report and I can have no criticism of
the way that this has been approached by
the conservative group I believe this
has been a properly collaborative
process so now we have more social
housing now we have Eastgate housing
coming in house now we had the 2030
target for a carbon neutral neutral
council now we had the press to model
community wealth building and now have
increased recycling all in the corporate
objectives all things put forward by the
Labour Party and adopted tonight
hopefully by the council this is how we
should work long may it continue thank
you very much indeed for that council
efforts once again very very positive do
members agree thank you very much indeed
moving on to agenda item 12 the annual
treasury management review for 2018 2019
I call upon councillor Davis Hondas
Thank You chairman members the report
before you this evening summarises
treasury management activity and
Prudential and Treasury indicators for
2018-19 the report has been considered
by the governance and Audit Committee on
the 24th of July and by a cabinet on
September the 19th this evening members
are asked to note to the actual 2018-19
Prudential and Treasury indicators in
this report and approve the annual
treasury management report for 2018-19
thank you german thank you very much
indeed counselor Saunders do you have a
seconder councillor Ashby
does no one wish that no one wishes to
speak on their do members agree
therefore thank you very much
moving on to agenda item 13 changes to
committees panels and board for 2019
2020 this is the nomination of members
to serve on committees do any group
leaders wish to take this opportunity to
advise of changes to their nominations
to committees panels and pause for the
remainder of 2019 2020 council Saunders
your microphone still on councillor
Piper Thank You chairman since the 24th
of September this year I've been serving
as the permanent member for the general
purposes committee and that's how it
will stay counts for the Braidwood who
was the permanent member has now become
the reserve of that committee and
councillor Braidwood is going to replace
me on governance and audit thank you
thank you very much councillor Piper do
any other leaders have any changes they
wish to make that is and no members that
concludes the business for the meeting
of the council this evening as you all
know we have an extraordinary council
meeting immediately following this I do
propose a five-minute recess to enable a
comfort break first of all thank you
very much indeed